昨日彼が火大会に行ってきたんだん
ああああああ
goo
行ったんですけどやっぱなんか静岡だからかなーいろんな人に声かけられて
なんかある男子高校生は2段っある女子高生は
たーっ
nani colle
みたいになんか色んな人がいたんですけど
すいませんちょっと僕一人見知りなんだよ
なんかウィリスとが入って変わっちゃいました皆祭花火の動画みたいとか言う貴公子の
方はぜひ
サブチャンネルから見てください動画の説明欄からも行きませんで皆さんパーなんでし
た次へは皆さんモンスターハンターとしてますがちょっとお友達たら好きなんでしょう
ね
モンスターをみんなで倒すゲームがあるんで僕めっちゃ好きなんですよモンスターだっ
た広かったですねほんとにもう j 者にかけたりしますか大学起点を1回モンスター
だったり埋まっちゃって
もうなんか4日間ぐらい哲也ねーし
倒したりしてましたねトナーモンスターハンターのすごいリアルのフィギュアがあるん
です
カップがフィギュアビルダーです
これは流れです
不ジェモラーしまで発売していないゲームのモンスターもいるんでしょ
これ何立パターンは違うテツカブラなテツカブラと
近々モンスターハンター4でるんだよ
皆さん是非しましょうです僕揺れて言ってですそれがわかんないんですけどね
何でるかな
ドスゲネポスがしてほしい亀頭
th
何よりこういうやばくねってかな胸入ってないんか
こういうフィギアケアをコレなにでるか書いてないんですけど
うんやベアー
ただ全然ほしいの言ったらてるあ子どもたちの君にはわからないんだろうね
フィギュアの素晴らしたらどうだ遠すぎればさこっちがその子分の
受けネポスです
ちっちっちあいわゆる雑魚敵というアレなんですけど噛まれたらまあ昼時があって
すごいいやらしいモンスターなんですよ
まあ僕がそんな人としか準備してないわけないですよ
これはね重さが違いますこちらも酸っぱいあたりですよ
あっん
全貌ラーシュ技術は壁から遅延暴乱して分からないでしょ
いわゆるラスボス的な雰囲気を漂わせた麻子
的みたいな感じです
どうせか良さは分からないしょ俺もわかんないよ
特徴としてはこの図のマネー
バリスタなんと対応で壊せるんですよ子青い国はねピッチで採取できるんですがここも
覚えておいてくださいね
parada ここがすごい切断できれるんで
双剣とかの人はここを狙ってください大剣とかもね
まあそんなところですかねこのひとつが同じ値段っていうことを
自体がおかしいですね世の中の不平等さを必死と感じております肇社長ですよ
dee